is it a competitive uh thing between fbi
and cia or no like is it like we're
better than you we're better it's more
like we work together it's like
firefighters versus cops when they play
the baseball yeah so
it's not even competitive because we're
so much better oh no no no no there you
go that's that's [ __ ]
no i i i'm not going to say that like i
know a lot of guys uh even though you're
the bureau and i i think very highly of
them
they are great but there was um
particularly pre-911 there was a there
was tension between the bureau and the
agency and
the bureau started putting their people
out in the field um overseas to take on
counter-terrorism uh
activity and that's always been sort of
the purview of of my outfit and so
that created some tension and and just
some confusion what are you guys doing
out here what's what's your objective
and why are you here and taking up our
space and and so that created some um
some
liaison problems in terms of sharing of
intelligence
and
you know so you'd you go in as an
example if you were operating somewhere
and you were engaged in a counter
terrorist operation
and the bureau uh came in and they were
doing some
you know activity and element you always
had this feeling like we weren't really
being completely square with each other
so we weren't really sharing uh you know
completely got it and and then why
though is it like who solves the mystery
and who solved it is that kind of what
it is yeah you know it's it was kind of
you know you're pissing on my turf right
and so how about you not it's
territorial
it was but now it's i will say this much
it is it is immensely improved um the
the liaison between the organizations is
is so much better now than it was again
15 10 years ago even collaborative
relationships
it's much better because you know in
part 911 forced that i mean you know you
suddenly realize look we there were
there were gaps there that did you know
we we probably could have avoided if we
but it's a human endeavor right it's
always going to there's always going to
be an element of risk you're never going
to minimize it down to zero if you
enjoyed this short clip click over here
to watch another short clip and if you
want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]